Speaker 1: Let's try instead.
Harry from Columbus, Ohio.
Speaker 3: David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Thank you so much for taking my call. Firstly,
I wanted to raise a quibble with how you
pronounce a certain set of words. Now,
whenever you are using the word historic, I
notice that you will say a or an historic, which
I have no understanding of why you would say
an historic. Could you care to explain that?
Speaker 1: Yeah. This is a this is a topic
of big debate among the grammar Nazis
and pronunciation experts. There are certain,
you know, typically the rule would be that if
the word starts with a vowel, it would be
an and if the word starts with a consonant,
it would be a. So a cat versus an apple.
Speaker 3: The thing about really quickly,
just before everyone. So I know what you're
talking about. And if we use the word, let's say
our like the hour of the day, we would say,
Oh, it took an hour to get there because we
pronounce the word hour with silent h. Yes.
Correct? Yes. The word historic. We do not
have a silent eight. We have a very hard h.
Speaker 1: The thing about Harry and I
apologize in order to fight back against your
interruption. I am now going to interrupt.
The thing about historic is there are some
words where, when pronounced in isolation,
they have a very clear consonant. Sound like if
I just say historic but historic has a relatively
soft age when in context. And that is why my
understanding is that it is acceptable to say an
historic and you're kind of running it together.
Speaker 3: If that is how you see it,
I can't disagree with that, we'll have to agree
to disagree on that. That's fair. Secondly,
real quickly and I wanted to get into this how
you feel about the analogy of answers completely,
you know, kind of fallen off the wagon a bit
and opinion. How do you feel about Josh Mandel
Gibbons with with the free note that Mandel ran
against senator? What's his? What's his name?
In 2012, he ran against the current
Democratic senator from Ohio. Sherrod lost.
Speaker 1: Listen, I think that they're all toxic.
I think that all of those Republican primary
candidates are all completely toxic now. You're
completely right. Listen, a couple of years ago,
I bought the book Hillbilly Elegy. Everybody said,
Listen, this book. This is a good story of growing
up in the rural poor white Midwest and South.
You'll understand conservatism. You should really
read this book, and I read J.D. Vance's book. And
first of all, I mean, his grandma, as he writes in
the book, was like a Kennedy Democrat. So it's not
even like it wasn't even that great of an exposé
about conservatism because his family was actually
sort of liberal. But anyway, I was like, OK, this
is like a thinking guy. And he has gone completely
off the rails, pro-Trump or at least hesitating
to criticize Trump and just bottom of the barrel
red meat his abs. I'm embarrassed that I thought
he was mildly reasonable after reading the book.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I can see where that perspective
came from, and a lot of people still hold that
perspective without their knowledge of what he
said otherwise. Now, real quickly, before I drop
Mandela, I think if Mandela starts the surge,
I don't think Trump will throw his
hat in the ring. I think he'll see
that Mendell lost in 2012. He's a loser, quote
unquote. Yeah. I expect Mike Gibbons to really
start to pull ahead if Trump nominates or endorsed
him. Trump has been extremely, extremely scared
to put his voice into this race. Yeah, I think
Speaker 1: he may just be waiting to see how it
shakes out before he does wins the primary there.
Speaker 3: The primary is May 3rd, but as you may
or may not have heard, we've had a lot of
issues regarding three national maps lots
of time in the Supreme Court of Ohio. And as of
yesterday, Ohio ACLU is suing the GOP map makers.
So it's still got a lot of story left to play out
here in Ohio. Thanks for taking the call, David.
Speaker 1: Hey, real quick, are you
talking through a voice modulator
or through some kind of metal screen
Speaker 3: that I am using a Bluetooth
headset that is probably not the other way of
talking? I'll try to get on a better microphone
next time we speak. Thank you. Beautiful.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you so much.
Appreciate the call. Of course. Wow, what a phone
call, guys. It is really something else today.